for over 40 years I've been a clinical
social worker and a developmental
psychologist and it seemed almost
natural for me to go into the helping
professions my parents had taught me to
do good for others and so I devoted my
career to working with families in some
of the toughest circumstances poverty
mental illness immigration refugees and
for all those years I've worked with
hope and with optimism in the past five
years though my hope and my optimism
have been put to the test I've been so
deeply disappointed in the way the
United States government is treating
families who are coming to our southern
border asking for asylum desperate
parents with children from El Salvador
Guatemala and Honduras who only want to
bring their kids to safety and security
they are fleeing some of the worst
violence in the world they've been
attacked by gangs assaulted raped
extorted threatened they have faced
death and they can't turn to their
police because the police are complicit
corrupt ineffective then they get to our
border and we put them in detention
centers prisons as if they were common
criminals back in 2014 I met some of the
first children in detention centers and
I went I sat in my car afterwards and I
cried I was seeing some of the worst
suffering I'd ever known and it would
against everything I believed in my
country the rule of law and everything
my parents taught me the way the United
States has handled the immigrant
seeking asylum in our country over the
past five years it's wrong just simply
wrong tonight I want to tell you the
children in immigration detention are
being traumatized and we are causing the
trauma we in America actually those of
us here tonight will not necessarily be
on the same page with respect to
immigration will disagree on how we're
gonna handle all those people want to
come to our country frankly it doesn't
matter to me whether if you're a
Republican or a Democrat liberal or
conservative no I want secure borders I
also want to keep the bad actors out I
want national security and of course
you'll have your ideas about those
topics too but I think we can agree that
America should not be doing harm the
government the state should not be in
the business of hurting children it
should be protecting them
no matter whose children they are your
children my grandchildren and the
children of families just looking for
asylum now I could tell you story after
story of children who have witnessed
some of the worst violence in the world
and are now sitting in detention but two
little boys have stayed with me over
these past five years one of them was
Danny Danny is seven and a half years
old when I met him in a detention center
in Caron City Texas back in 2014 he was
there with his mother and his brother
and they had fled Honduras
you know then he's one of these kids you
get to love instantly he's funny he's
innocent he's charming and very
expressive and he's drawing pictures for
me and one of the pictures he drew for
me was of the rebels locos the rebels
locos these this is the name that they
gave the gangs in the town that he was
in
I said to Danny Danny what makes them
bad guys then he looked at me with
puzzlement I mean the look was more like
are you clueless or just stupid he
leaned in and he whispered don't you see
they smoked cigarettes and they drink
beer
Danny had learned of course about the
evils of drinking and smoking then he
said and they carry guns in one of the
pictures the stick figures of the
devil's locos are shooting at birds and
at people Danny told me about the day
his uncle was killed by those rebels
locos and how he ran from his house to
his uncle's farm house only to see his
uncle's dead body his face disfigured by
bullets and Danny told me he saw his
uncle's teeth coming out of the back of
his head he was only six at the time
sometime after that one of those rebels
locals beat little Danny badly severely
and that's when his parents said we have
got to leave or they will kill us so
they set out but Danny's father was a
single leg amputee with a crutch and he
couldn't manage the rugged terrain so he
said to his wife go without me take our
boys save our boys so mom and the boys
set off Danny told me he looked back
said goodbye to his father looked back a
couple of times it's until he lost sight
of his father and in detention he had
not heard of his heard from his father
and it's very likely that his father was
killed by the trebles locos because he
had tried to flee I can't forget Danny
the other boy was Fernando now Fernando
was in the same detention centre roughly
the same age as Danny Fernando is
telling me about the 24 hours he spent
in isolation with his mother in the
detention centre placed there because
his mother had led a hunger strike among
the mothers in the detention center
and now she was cracking under the
pressure of the guards who were
threatening and being very abusive
towards her and Fernando as Fernando and
I are talking in the small office his
mother burst in and she says they hear
you they're listening to you and she
dropped to her hands and knees and she
began to look under the table groping
under all the chairs she looked at the
electric sockets at the corner of the
room the floor the corner of the
ceilings at the lamp at the air vents
looking for hidden microphones and
cameras
I watched Fernando as he watched his
mother spiral into this paranoid state I
looked in his eyes and I saw utter
terror after all who would take care of
him if she couldn't it was just the two
of them they only had each other I could
tell you story after story but I haven't
forgotten Fernando and I know something
about what that kind of trauma stress
and adversity does to children so I'm
gonna get clinical with you for a moment
and I'm gonna be the professor that I am
under prolonged and intense stress
trauma hardship adversity harsh
conditions the developing brain is
harmed plain and simple it's wiring and
it's architecture are damaged the
child's natural stress response system
is affected it's weakened of its
protective factors regions of the brain
that are associated with cognition
intellectual abilities judgment trusts
self-regulation and social interaction
are weakened sometimes permanently that
impairs children's future we also know
that under stress the child's immune
system is suppressed making them
susceptible to infections chronic
illnesses like diabetes asthma
cardiovascular disease will
all those children into adulthood and
likely shorten their lives mental health
problems are linked to the breakdown of
the body I have seen children in
detention who have recurrent and
disturbing nightmares night terrors
depression and anxiety dissociative
reactions hopelessness suicidal thinking
and post-traumatic stress disorders and
they regress in their behavior like the
11-year old boy who began to wet his bed
again
after years of continence and the eight
year old girl who was buckling under the
pressure and was insisting that her
mother breastfeed her that is what the
tension does to children now you may ask
what do we do what should our government
do well I'm just a mental health
professional so all I really know is
about children's health and development
but I have some ideas first we need to
reframe our practices we need to replace
fear and hostility with safety and
compassion we need to tear down the
prison walls the barbed wires take away
the cages instead of prison or prisons
we should create orderly asylum
processing centers campus-like
communities where children and families
can live together we could take old
motels old army barracks refit them so
that children and parents can live as
family units in some safety and
normality where kids can run around in
these processing centers pediatricians
family doctors dentists and nurses would
be screening examining treating and
immunizing children creating records
that will follow them to their next
medical provider social workers would be
conducting mental health evaluations
and providing treatment for those who
needed those social workers would be
connecting families to services that
they're going to need wherever they're
headed and teachers would be teaching
and testing children and documenting
their learning needs so that the
teachers at the next school can continue
those children's education there's a lot
more that we could do in these
processing centers a lot more and you
probably are thinking this is pie in the
sky stuff can't blame you well let me
tell you that refugee camps all over the
world are holding families like those in
our detention centers and some of those
refugee camps are getting it right far
better than we are
the United Nations has issued reports
describing refugee camps that protect
children's health and development
children and parents live in family
units and clusters our families are
housed together parents are given work
permits so they can earn some money
they're giving food vouchers so they can
go to the local stores and shop mothers
are brought together to cook healthy
meals for the children and children go
to school every day and are talked
afterwards after school they go home and
they ride bikes hang out with friends do
homework and explore the world all the
essentials for child development we can
get it right we have the resources to
get it right what we need is the will
and the insistence of Americans that we
treat children humanely you know I I I
can't forget
Danny or Fernando I wonder where they
are today and I pray that they are
healthy and happy there are only two of
them many children I met and of the
thousands we know about who have been in
detention
I may be saddened by what's happened to
the children
but I'm inspired by them I may cry as I
did but I admire those children's
strengths they keep alive my hope in my
optimism and the work I do so while we
may differ on our approach to
immigration we should be treating
children with dignity and respect we
should do right by them if we do we can
prepare those children who remain in the
United States prepare them to become
productive engaged members of our
society and those who will return to
their countries for whether voluntarily
or not will be prepared to become the
teachers the merchants the leaders in
their country and I hope together all of
those children and parents could give
testimony to the world about the
goodness of our country and our values
but we have to get it right
so we can agree to disagree on
immigration but I hope we can agree on
one thing that none of us wants to look
back at this moment in our history when
we knew we were inflicting lifelong
trauma on children and that we sat back
and did nothing that would be the
greatest tragedy of all thank you
[Applause]